nous continuons nous de défendre laame
parce que la supprimé c'est dangereux
médicalement c'est absurde
économiquement et c'est indigne
moralement des questions sont parfois
posé sur l'aide médicale
d'État la question aujourd'hui n'est pas
de fermer le débat parce que quand un
dispositif bénéficie à 350000 personnes
à peu près il est normal que nous soyons
en tant que LG ateur vigilant attentif à
son mode de fonctionnement à son mode
d'accès au à la possibilité des
bénéficiaires de vraiment en bénéficier
quand nous savons que tout le monde n'en
bénéficie pas alors qu'il pourrait tout
à fait y avoir droit il s'agit donc pas
de mentir au au français quel que soit
ce qu'on pense de l'amee de sa
transformation puisqueà coup sû le
Conseil constitionnel va va censurer ce
ce ce cavalier si le montant de cette
ame est forte c'est pas parce que il y a
davantage de coûts pour le système de
soins par unité de personn mais bien
parce qu'il y a plus d'immigrés en
situation irrégulière qui est sur notre
sol donc laame n'est que le thermomètre
du nombre de personnes irrégulières qui
ne repartent pas de notre territoire et
donc le but de pour de faire diminuer la
me si on voulait avoir ce but là et
c'est le but que peut avoir tout bon
gestionnaire public c'est moins moins de
personnes en situation étrangère
irrégulière sur notre territoire c'est
le but du projet loi des cas de fraude
qui ont pu être identifié était au
nombre de 38 que finalement le coût de
cette me est extrêmement faible ça
représente
0,4 % des quelques 204 milliards d'euros
de dépenses en matière de soins en
France et puis peut-être regarder ce
qu'on fait les voisins l'Espagne avait
supprimé laame pour pour les même raison
malsine que celles qui ont présidé à cet
ajout du côté du Sénat et 2 ans après
ils ont renoncé et ils ont remis en
œuvre la me y compris parce qu'ils
avaient constaté une augmentation très
importante euh de la mortalité du côté
des exilés un/ers des Français ont déjà
renoncé à des soins faute de moyens
qu'un sur de déclare peiné à se soigner
que le gouvernement d'ailleurs ces
dernières années a continué à diminuer
le remboursement des soins pour les
Français pendant ce temps-là le nombre
de bénéficiaires de la me lui il
augmente vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre il augmente forcément à
proportion de de l'augmentation de
l'immigration qui touche le pays 82 %
d'augmentation ces 10 dernières années
c'est considérable